so it's been interesting look
I'm coming in and it looks like
into two major groups and the first
being this question of adaptation how do
we respond right here in New England to
these kinds of impacts the other main
theme that's very clear is people
wanting to move very quickly beyond this
question of adaptation to mitigation
given the scale and size of the impacts
and the warming that we're now expecting
some many people in the audience are
actually quite interested in moving on
to well what do we do to prevent these
changes to begin with but let's start
with the adaptation side and there's a
number of comments here that are
stronger than the way I would say this
so but let me say it this way that's
nuts that's why we have questions from
the audience my question would be the
given the sea level rise and greater
storm surge is now expected in the
future how should we be rethinking
coastal zoning policies other people put
it a little more bluntly shouldn't we
ban zone or zone out all rebuilding in
flood areas along the coast as an
example and if houses on the shore hit
and destroyed why is it that it's still
legal to live so close to the seashore
okay so clearly these are some of the
critical questions and these aren't easy
because there are reasons why we like
the straw life and this is spectacular
beautiful places to live 99% of the time
but then come these moments when
suddenly these places that we love and
cherish and have long-standing cultural
affinities to in many cases are suddenly
deeply harmed and then we have to
respond and try to recover and as we
said before rebuilding a smarter and
stronger way so let me throw that open
to the to the panel of how do we grapple
with this tension let me just start by
saying two things about that I think the
comment is spot on the you can talk
about the stone house but the stone
house I think has been flooded twice in
the last three years and they've rebuilt
twice or done substantial renovations
twice and it's going again
and clearly that was paid for in part by
some pretty you know substantial
insurance returns that being said as of
maybe a month or two ago when I was in
Milford for a similar event there were
still a thousand people who had not
gotten back into their homes because
it's some level the new FEMA building
standards has actually become a barrier
to people getting back in their homes
because the insurance proceeds don't
meet the costs of actually rebuilding a
home up to the current standards and so
to some extent if we're smart about new
building standards though there will be
some level of building and rebuilding
that won't occur after these storms let
me give you there a million barriers and
I think we've talked a lot about just
some of the social and psychological
barriers we love the shoreline it is the
identity of this state in a lot of ways
but here's another one our system of
local taxation is a barrier to policy
change because these are expensive
properties on the shoreline and they
make a lot of money for municipalities
and without anywhere else to go for
towns
other than the property tax and with
really no ability to regionally plan in
this state so as to make a deal with
Milford that if you have more
restrictive zoning on your shoreline and
you lose all the property tax revenue
associated with big expensive how homes
that are on those roads will make up for
that
by giving you a little bit of the
revenue that comes from the new factory
that gets located inland a town up into
the state without the ability to do that
towns on the shoreline aren't left with
any real incentive structure to do
restrictive zoning because that's where
their bread is is butter and their
schools don't run unless you have homes
there so we've got to have a statewide
conversation not simply about regional
land use planning but around the way in
which we tax because if we do a better
job of sharing tax revenues then
there'll be less pressure on those
municipalities to continue to build and
rebuild and rebuild along the shoreline
well yeah I was going to agree with
here when you're in working in these
small towns in these and you start
realizing that essentially they are you
know over twenty thirty percent of their
tax base is made up of these some of
these large coastal dwellers and also
when part of it is that many of these
houses aren't in locations that are
necessarily in harm's way they're
they're high up a lot of them are you
know part of the the bigger issue
becomes egress and some of the
infrastructure concerns and the cost for
maintaining Road and access so the
problem the problems that these face are
not so simple it's not it's not just the
idea of establishing a method of retreat
has major implications on the towns and
the coasts not to mention the
infrastructure on the coast so it's a
it's a much bigger deal than making
choices about about immediate retreat on
the other hand I think there's there is
opportunity to think strategically
around land planning on these coastal
areas so we've started to look at ways
of connecting roads where there's maybe
a small barrier between one road and
another where you could bypass roads
along the coasts Soundview for example
in Guilford it's interesting because
it's actually where much of the industry
is located but but but it floods
periodically and so we're thinking about
how you might be able to bypass some of
the roadways but then you get into the
question of where do you locate in your
industrial corridor if and if not
they're the people inland aren't they're
not necessarily interested in that
having that industrial corridor and
their backyard so you get into a whole
discussion across the town about larger
land use negotiations that are you know
fairly complex meanwhile if we remove
these large homeowners or create a
situation where their property value
goes down that then you lose funding
that's going into the schools that's
supporting your children so it's it's
all interconnected but the single
largest legend sure is actually the
federal government through the National
Flood Insurance Program
and prior to Hurricane sandy there was a
large-scale reform to move to actually
sound rates he might I think can't even
quantify the number of subsidizing
grandfather's properties currently with
the taxpayers dollars but moving forward
over the next five to ten years
homeowners that have insurance policies
and business owners that have NFIP
policies are gonna see very large in
some cases very large rates on their
premium increases which is going to have
the effect of looking at the national
level it's not just a question of beach
houses and second homes and wealthy land
owners of the five and a half percent of
the population that lives in flood
plains it's the exact same number of low
and moderate income dwellers as in not
the flood plains right so it's not just
a question of the beach houses that
impacts everyone so is there more that
people want to say about how the policy
environment can be changed because look
there's decision making that happens at
every level at the federal level at the
state level at the community level and
at the individual level and so we are
the inheritors I think you use the word
the legacy of the governance systems and
the decision-making systems which we've
evolved over many hundreds of years in
some cases
how do those need to change to help
people make those individual choices for
example in a new way so I mean you
mentioned the insurance is a big stick
and I think we're already seeing many
major insurers have pulled out of the
state of Florida as an example because
they see it is just too risky but what
happens then government usually steps in
and says okay we will support you and
that sounds good in the interim but then
comes the next major hurricane in
Florida and the state of Florida and all
the taxpayers of Florida are now on the
hook same kinds of issues I'm sure going
to face us here in New England so how do
we square this well part of it is making
people that don't live on the shoreline
understand that all of these discussions
affect them because they are paying for
either the flood insurance that is
cheaper because of their subsidy or
remediation that has to be done or the
seawall that has to be rebuilt and I
think there's just been a real dichotomy
of conversation in Connecticut I
probably imagine it exists in the rest
of the country in which you know people
that live inland just don't think that
this is something that affects them and
you know not that we want to set up a
situation in which you've got the inland
homeowners against the shoreline
homeowners but we do have to we do have
to have other people step in and and and
push because there's a powerful
political constituency amongst the
people that live on the shoreline and
it's something that every you know like
that official has to pay attention to
and if there's not any pushback coming
from those that are subsidizing that
living and rebuilding and remediation
then then it's a difficult trap
politically to get out of then as an
inland dweller myself I've often thought
of what a wonderful state this is in
terms of its coastal parks having assets
Sherwood and so on but wouldn't it be
even a greater state if there were more
public land along the coastline so
here's another way in which the inland
growler has a stake in the future of
this if some of the zoning could have a
result of an increased public access to
the coastline that would be a broad
benefit I believe I'm from Massachusetts
so I think I should say something about
Massachusetts we're in a disaster
comparable in some ways to Florida sand
the way that evolved was that the
homeowners along the coast agitated for
the state to cap private insurance rates
which they proceeded to do which caused
a big exodus from Cape Cod Martha's
Vineyard Nantucket of the insurers so
within a year or two most property
owners that this place has got notices
from their insurance companies that
their policies wouldn't be renewed so
then there was another uproar which
resulted very similar to Florida in the
state coming in with a its own plan
ironically called the fair plan which is
a massive subsidization of
quite wealthy people on the beach by
less wealthy people inland and so the
root of the problem and I agree with the
senator others and I talked to a lot of
insurance people in Massachusetts is
that we have a lot of people inland
subsidizing risk on the coast and if we
keep doing that through all the means
we've talked about we're gonna keep
having a problem and I think it takes
political courage to say as I think you
said for the National Flood Insurance
Program that premiums ought to reflect
risk people want to build in a dangerous
base okay it's a free country but don't
make everyone else pay for that risk so
let me make one significant caveat to
that because I think it's and and I
started this conversation so I'm
conditioning myself here I think what
we're talking about right is these big
houses that sit literally on the
shoreline but as flood maps move further
inland and and frankly as you just look
at the experience of flooding in some of
our coastal cities like Stanford and
Bridgeport we're gonna be dealing with
flood prone areas that include a lot of
very low-income neighborhoods as well
and so one of the caveats here and
things to be careful about is that
should you shift a lot of the risk onto
the homeowners or the landlord's you're
gonna get a lot of those three million
dollar homes on the shoreline but you
may also get a lot of low-income
properties in Bridgeport and Stanford in
Norwalk as well the fact is we have an
enormous ly high percentage of low
income individuals and families living
within about a mile or to the shoreline
in Connecticut just by how our
development patterns work and so I don't
and I don't have the solution to this
because theoretically it makes sense
except to say that we are stuck with a
building pattern in the state that puts
a lot of housing pretty close to the
shoreline and you just got to be careful
about who has to pay those prices in
general I think we're we're recognizing
that that our urbanization trends and
the way in which we've built out
particular suburbanization etc or is not
a sustainable configuration of you know
and it creates all kinds of behavioral
patterns that are problematic for
emissions etc I've seen climate change
adaptation and efforts along the coast
because in the pressures that are coming
to play now and the decisions that are
being made as a kind of canary of the
future need for modifying urbanization
strategies more broadly so I think that
there is an opportunity to think about
this proactively and to develop to think
about buffers along riparian systems and
about about floodplain zones and about
you know erosion control areas and to
rethink parts of the coast where
possible in an innovative fashion that
could then inform the rest of our sort
of future reorganisation strategies you
know rethinking how we value ecosystem
services themselves so that's a pose you
know thinking about how we're
subsidizing certain kinds of development
that end up being costly but also you
know I think the point about the parks
is a really important one I think that
deep
they're provided by different kinds of
ecosystem development so how do you
start to put a value on that and invest
in that as well so another theme that is
emerged in the questions comes back to
the bigger picture I mean we've seen how
incredibly vulnerable in New England has
already been to the kinds of extremes
that we've just experienced in the past
couple of years I mean billions of
dollars lives lost lives destroyed
businesses lost etc and that's with a
very limited amount of climate change so
far and as we saw in the beginning we're
potentially looking at three four five
six degrees or more centigrade of
warming so I guess the question comes
back to especially those working on the
solutions side you know are we talking
about you know solutions that really are
only appropriate for another one degree
or how does this conversation start to
change as we take seriously the prospect
of going well beyond two degrees into
much greater climate impacts well and I
clearly fall Sun squarely on the
shoulders of those of us you know in in
policy positions but these guys should
comment too so I think a lot of us
thought that the world was going to be
different after sandy that how could you
deny that there was a substantial impact
on the weather patterns of this country
after sandy and the fact is is that
things did not change that there are
still just as many people who deny that
climate change is happening after sandy
as did beforehand and so in Washington
right now it seems pretty clear that you
were gonna need a political revolution
that you were gonna need a public
opinion an electoral revolution to
really get this issue across the finish
line we came close to a very big climate
bill in 2009 we passed it by a very
small margin in the House of
Representatives and I
think we had nearly 50 votes in the
Senate but of course not nearly enough
to clear a filibuster but we've gone
nowhere but backwards since then we have
nowhere near the majority of the house
and you know we probably have less than
50 votes clearly today in the Senate and
so it is going to have to rise to one of
the top one two or three issues that
people go to the polls to vote on before
it really changes before the debate in
Washington fundamentally changes again
there is good news happening on the
international front and I think other
nations are waking up to the need to do
this and so we may be able to get some
international agreements but much of
that conversation is chilled by the fact
that the last time we got a big
international agreement it went down in
a unanimous vote in the United States
Senate 97 to 0 or not maybe was 97 to 3
but it was an overwhelming rejection in
the Senate so memories of that sometimes
chile international negotiations but you
really need it is really all about the
electoral politics now in order to to
change some votes in the Senate in the
house you know at the state level
there's a lot of exciting work that's
happening I think that there is having
worked at the federal level at do-e and
in the White House that the council
Environmental Quality and then coming to
Connecticut
it is very exciting to see the
commitment that has been here in this
state and in this region starting to
ripple out to other states and part of
that is some of the solutions that we
are we've always been aware of in terms
of in the electricity sector increasing
the supply of renewables or increasing
our conservation of energy through
energy efficiency we've gotten smarter
about how to do efficiency and the
economics of renewables solar panels for
example have changed dramatically so
that the cost effectiveness of these
solutions and the and the effectiveness
is is getting better every day
and
I mentioned the Regional Greenhouse Gas
Initiative which Connecticut has been a
leader in launching that and we are
starting to see through the the
presidents Climate Action Plan the
conversation in Washington focusing on
regulation of existing power plants
we're starting to see an opportunity for
potentially other states that have not
had perhaps the motivation to think
about solutions like Reggie the Regional
Greenhouse Gas Initiative start to be
interested in how that's worked here in
Connecticut and we have a great story to
tell in terms of the jobs that is
created here in the state by virtue of
oxygen and carbon and allowances and
being able to reinvest those proceeds in
efficiency and clean energy development
Connecticut doesn't have any native
fossil fuel resources we import every
all the hydrocarbons that we burn to
keep the lights on we are paying another
state to produce those and so the more
that we do efficiency the more that we
do installation of renewables here in
the state the more that we're seeing
those economic benefits which is
critical because of the difficulty of
keeping the competitiveness particularly
of our manufacturing sector where we
have high electricity prices so there
are many reasons including trying to
bend the curve and and reduce our carbon
emissions for us to be proud of the
progress and redouble our commitment to
continued progress on some of these
initiatives in the electricity sector
and I'll just add you know the the the
big next or not next question we're
aware of it but then the next challenge
is how do you capture some of the carbon
reductions in the transportation sector
and that's where I think some of the
expertise of those who are working on
land-use planning issues and working
with communities around transit oriented
it's it's gonna be really important to
leverage that experience to figure out
that there's a there's a lot of
potential there and we need some
redoubled effort and new models we've
had a lot of focus under the the
comprehensive energy strategy that we
released in February of this year on
provided as a platform an infrastructure
platform for alternative fuel vehicles
and we're very excited about the
progress that we're making there but I
think the there's a there's a lot of
need for new ideas in progress in the
transportation sector to keep pace with
what we've been able to do in
electricity yeah I would I would add the
last graph that I showed were there's
sort of an increase in understanding of
green infrastructure and potential kind
of growth of of size and scale of action
in my mind that you know reality is
we're going towards a world in which
events and risks and challenges are
increasing so I'm assuming I have to
assume that over time we're going to
continually we're going to have more of
these events that in our face and it's
going to have you know a progressive
influence on what we're willing to do
and how how we're willing as a society
to kind of adopt or accommodate and I
think we need to be proactive about
anticipating that build on some of the
changes that are taking place where you
know companies are starting to work
together or there's is some
interdisciplinarity or effort to try to
bridge across gaps you know there's also
this kind of bottom-up there's a real
change in the next generation and and
I'm assuming the generation after that
in terms of the younger younger
generations thinking more broadly
thinking about the world and
anticipating these concerns it's I think
it's tough to grow up in a world where
you are looking at some of the stuff
that Ron and others showed and
anticipate that's what you have to look
forward to as an adult and and so it's
up to me and I wouldn't give up hope but
I also think that there you know I'm
sort of trying to maintain my optimistic
perspective on the that humans can
change and that we can kind of pull
together and adapt to some of these but
I always it it's clearly going to be
more disaster
future and I think that's gonna have an
impact I'm glad the issue of energy came
up it's a it's a complex subject to look
at the intersection of climate change
and energy resources but maybe the one
well the one positive thing in all this
bad news we heard is that the the other
as I show the the wintertime
precipitation over eastern Canada
especially in the hydro-quebec area is
going to increase so in terms of getting
our electrical energy from the north
okay we have to pay for it but that's
something that may work a little bit in
our advantage with respect to the
climate change that's about the only
it's a very timely comment actually
because we have been very focused on
hydropower large-scale hydropower in
Canada as a possible source of a greater
amount of electric electric generation
for New England not just here in
Connecticut but all across the area
because you know it's it's we right now
our electricity generation here in
Connecticut is half powered by natural
gas and half by nuclear from the
Millstone power plant and we've seen
with the vermont yankee power plant
announcing just recently that they would
be decommissioning you know that we look
at millstone and we wonder you know do
we need to plan for a more diverse
supply of electricity in Connecticut and
so we've been engaged in conversations
with with other states about this -
obviously you need to build the
transmission to bring the hydro into the
region and how would you actually do
that that you know it's it's very
complex but I think it's it's got to be
considered I think it's a it's an
important resource and could improve the
diversity and therefore the reliability
of our electric system so I think it's
fair to say that this is a conversation
that's just beginning
and in fact I would say that's in fact
one of the most important things
certainly in our work looking at how the
public nationally and in states and
frankly around the world are responding
to this issue is that we're not
fundamentally talking about it and I
think this conversation needs to happen
again and again and again everywhere
because global climate change turns out
is not a distant problem it's not
distant in time we're talking a
generation or more and it's not distant
in space it's not just going to happen
to polar bears in small island countries
this is happening for all of us and this
question of how are we vulnerable and
how are we going to respond is raising
these really deep questions because it
raises that question respond to what how
effectively and at what cost can we in
fact respond to and just adapt our way
out of a four-degree world I think the
more we really grapple with this as
local communities the more we will also
in turn come to realize this is why
mitigation is so important this is why
reducing fossil fuel use is so important
so I know that the Yale climate energy
is - thanks everyone for coming this is
the beginning of a conversation that yci
continues or intends to continue over
coming months and years so thank you
again please let's give a